in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
quarantine edition
and you know i gotta say this i have
done genius brain so many different
times but i've never done it on a zoom
podcast before
and i was thinking to myself everybody
wanted me to talk about the whole kobe
situation
and i was like i don't know why you want
me to talk about kobe i don't know [ __ ]
i was like i don't know any doctors i
don't know a single
you better not have said you don't know
any doctors that's what i got
any doctors this is as i'm talking to
gobble i'm like man do you know any
doctors that you can recommend me to
i will i will leave a knife in your
bladder my friend
and then and then i will i will save
your bladder
and i'll stitch it right back up look at
you you son of a [ __ ] now you back on
the
everybody's been asking you uh to come
back to the podcast and the thing that
they remember about you the most
is when you left me in a sikh temple the
bow
that's that's your calling card listen
that was uh the communication wasn't
great we
uh we we you know didn't call a good
audible
and uh we ended up not in a great
situation now the the audible was that
we weren't going to do it that was the
good audible
and then you backed out last minute um
you know we should leave some things in
the past let's move forward we're in a
quarantine we got bigger things to worry
about david there's
there's a pandemic going on it's a pain
you
so i mean the reason why like okay first
of all you know i feel like
a lot of people who there's one thing
that kind of
that got me that denzel washington said
right so denzel washington i was
remember he was watching this
uh i was watching an interview of him
and um
they wanted him to give a statement
about media right and i don't really
consider myself
quote-unquote news or media i mean this
is just a podcast
it's very casual uh it's all fun and
games right
right but the thing that denzel
washington that kind of said something
in this interview that really stuck out
to me he goes
a lot of news facets or people who are
in media they
they don't like to it's not about right
information it's about who can come out
with the information first
right right and so and i understand that
game like in social media game
in in any of this type of stuff like if
you're not the first one there then your
information becomes dated you won't get
a lot of views
uh people won't care about your your
video they will click on it and i
understand that
but like something like with kobit and
the reason why i bring that up is
because i
i'm you know besides talking about it
here and there i didn't want to do a
full dedicated video to it because i
really don't know
anything about this right and not only
do i not know about this i think
everybody who thinks that they do know
stuff about this they're not really
talking to physicians they're not
talking to doctors they're not talking
about people who are in the hospital
who's actually dealing with this stuff
so i was like i might as well just bring
you on here doctor
might as well uh yeah yeah no man i
think um
i think there's a lot of you know i
think the the benefit about living in
this time is there's a lot of
uh information that's shared the the
downside of that is there's a lot of
misinformation that gets shared i mean
i know that even when this first started
like in the black community
they're like oh you know and the melanin
that we got
protects us from you know coronavirus oh
for real that was the thing
in the very beginning right and then and
then it turns out
that you know um the african-american
black community is like
one of the hardest hit with mortality
right so then it's so so then it's
very dangerous the amount of
misinformation that happens
and you know and then there's like
lighter stuff where people think it's
caused by 5g towers i'm sure you're
going to get
stuff in here anyways
but there's a lot of misinformation and
i want to um
you know i you know i want to caveat
anything i say
and that i'm i'm a so i'm a family
medicine doctor i'm not
um an infectious disease specialist um i
work um both inpatient outpatient in my
last year residency so we do do a fair
number of
icu work and emergency department work
um
i have taken care of a few covet
patients
not a lot i'm not in a new york
emergency room
um and i could share what we found um
but again if anybody's looking for any
standardized guidelines i would say like
cdc
world health organization are still like
the you know those are the experts like
dr fauci
dr burks that's why health people do you
do you do you know
what the reason why covet affects like
the african-american community
more severely than other ones like what
what's the reason behind that
right so um so the the the thought
is because because it's not as far as
it's affecting them more
as far as i'm catching it it's yeah more
of them are dying from it
um the belief right now is it's uh
it's highlighting as dr foundry said
it's highlighting a discrepancy that
already existed so there's a lot more
disparities in those communities so your
higher levels of
like um hypertension or high blood
pressure uh diabetes
obesity um you know respiratory disease
asthma those type of things
that tend to be more prevalent in some
of these communities just
put like if you just think of it as your
force field so your force feels lowered
because you already have these other
things going on that affect your immune
system
yeah i was reading up a lot of stuff
where i i guess like when
we're talking about numbers of people
who are infected with covet and the
mortality rate of it
right it's not as simple just to say
they're dying because of kobe right
it's it's like there's compound issues
it's it's not just covet comes into
their system they were completely
healthy
and then coven was the killer it's it's
a compound thing though covet is the
thing that
that set them over the edge that caused
the death you have to look
at a litany of things of why code
affected them
uh in such a manner you know i
i think so i think the you know i i
hesitate to say yes
right right i think um the name of this
um virus is the novel coronavirus right
if you look at its name like the sars
virus that happened a few years back uh
it had this is basically
it's the same name like sars cove ii
right so it's like a similar
uh virus but it's also called the novel
coronavirus
it's new meaning that we we are
we are learning in real time a lot of
the things that we're doing like
you know for the the first two months
like the treatments that we were doing
um we didn't know if they worked there
was like
there's you're and because
our normal methods of treatment right is
that
they'll be these very like randomized
controlled studies
uh at these big institutions who will
try out these medications
um you'll see these numbers experts will
weigh in and say yes this is what
we think would will be the risks and
benefits
have been evaluated and we believe the
benefit of this treatment
um far outweighs any risk right
um but because this is so new and it's
spread so fast
um any treatment you know that
we want to try it's not steady yet you
know
we have to like if someone's in our icu
and someone's dying
you know you're gonna you're gonna like
and you're talking to your friends who
are
in new york connecticut somewhere else
um who are dealing who are doing who are
seeing some things
and they're like hey you know i tried
this on some of my patients and we're
getting
um you know some beneficial responses so
you try it but it's not necessarily as
evidence-based as would like to be so
it's a very interesting place so
going back to original question um
you know the way that coronavirus
kills we don't 100 know we do know that
in some cases it can cause um
this um very extreme um
almost um inflammatory uh
damage to your lungs um similar to yeah
so
um and then we do know that um it
creates a lot of hypoxia or low oxygen
right
um um so we know that um that's a way
there's some people who saw you know in
some
patients you start having higher degrees
of
what we call like um hypercoagulability
or basically like your blood gets
thicker
and you get more you know you get more
clots to
vital areas um and you know and i think
we see that we see more kidney failure
and some like acute
like so we call it acute kidney injury
so you see some of that
there's a number of different ways that
the virus is presented and hasn't been
um black and white and saying yo if
someone gets this
they're going to go out like this you
you don't know even today in new york
times you're talking about like
um you know children are presenting with
the interesting
symptoms that you know you know in
conjunction with coronavirus that we
haven't seen before
and they don't know we don't know what
that is you know it could be nothing it
could be something
uh before you know the one thing that we
knew is that you know this didn't tend
to affect
healthy young children and adolescents
as much
as adults and people who have you know
comorbidities
um but you know every day
something you could come out and when
doctors like what is this they were like
i don't know let's
go and you just and you kind of come and
you're compiling data like i mean like i
think
there's gonna be a big analysis of
everything that went down in 2019
20 um and then if this goes on until
next year which looks like it might um
you know it's going to be looking at all
this stuff that we did
and and all these patterns and trying to
get a better idea about
okay we think that this
constellation of symptoms or
presentations is associated directly
with the virus or
this was coincidental yeah because
because
you know the hard part for me is that i
you know when i
when i read this stuff online right and
and you know i i have
i have a medical insurance for for for
whenever i go to a hospital i also have
a
yeah i also pay for primary care i
specialize like primary care if i if i
need something really quick
i just pay an extra it's like an extra
150 bucks a month and for me that's
important
um i think like now that we're getting
older it's important for me so like
anytime i feel something wrong with
myself like i i hit up the primary care
doctor that's in the app
right and i'm like hey do i got corona
yeah because like
i'm freaking the [ __ ] out because when i
read the list of the possible
uh secondary side effects of what you
can have for corona it's like my
everyday pain
you know they're like oh if you have a
slight cough or you have a headache or
your bones hurt or you might have chills
i'm like that's everything like how do
how do we how do i not know or how do i
know if i have this or not
you know yeah it's it's hard man i think
part of what makes this virus so
um you know so insidious i guess it's
the best word or
um the spread like this has made it go
from like a
a localized thing that we you know
attribute to be
starting in wuhan um to becoming a
global pandemic
um is that the presentation
doesn't necessarily hit you with a very
very sick presentation for most people
right yeah like for the majority of
people it
it might be mistaken for a common
um respiratory virus which you know
the common cold it hit like if you think
about it hit like in
um you know winter 2019 uh 2020
and so you so at the same time that you
have cough cold
uh going on you also have this disease
brewing
so it's so people who
have like you said non-specific we call
it non-specific symptoms that's kind of
how we like to describe them
you have cough cold general malaise like
you're just feeling like icky
um you're the dangerous thing is that
you're
you're what we call shedding the virus
so until like so they think like the
peak time before
um you know a viral shedding is up until
you have
um all the manifestation of your
symptoms so
we know fever is very common with it and
we know that
a dry cough um and then oil
what is it what exactly does a dry cough
mean okay
so um that's that's that's an easy
question so um
some coughs like have you ever um have
you ever had like a really bad
um cold or something when you're
coughing and then some stuff comes out
like
and stuff yeah so that's uh sputum so
that's a
what we call a wet cough a dry cough is
you're coughing but
you're not producing any sputum
so that's what a dragon so a dry cough
is just nothing's coming up it's just
you're coughing
but you're consistently coughing though
for no damn reason like
well i mean it varies right that's
that's the thing so the main thing with
coronavirus is that
this thing is is like a doppelganger it
could be so many different things
so it was going around spreading so the
only like great comparison that like
i've heard
people like um and
um give an analogy to is like ebola so
ebola if you got ebola
you are sick ad can i cut us on this
thing oh you cuz
you say whatever the [ __ ] you want you
are sick of [ __ ] all right yeah
so and and and then so you're sick of
[ __ ]
um you it's like like especially if you
have like the hemorrhagic type
all the all these you know like all
these things going on
um and so people are people are able to
look at you
like this person is sick it's like let's
let's
let's quarantine him off you know make
sure that whoever is touching him we're
like watching for symptoms too
but we are going to like quarantine this
person off and we are just going to be
like very vigilant
about how we bury him how we move them
who goes in and out who touches him who
touches his waist
all that stuff right but with this
you know if you got this if like say say
you got it and your case was what we
call
mild right so you have like you had like
you had some chills you had like a
little temperature
you have some cough you're just not
feeling great like
normally like you would probably go to
work still
try i mean like you you probably still
try to do your podcast try to do some
things
you know still you know sleep next to
your fiance
all these things that you know that you
do as your activities of daily life
but you're spreading the virus
and you don't even know oh you don't
know yeah and that's what happened here
like so a lot of people you know i'm not
going to say everybody but most people
most people we we attributed they
probably had some mild symptoms and
they're still spreading it
but what the the blockbuster i guess
realization and why we changed
to this whole like universal masking
thing you know yeah right
one of these joints is that um
you know cdc world health organization
came out and they're talking about like
there's probably a lot of
asymptomatic spread so people who who
get the virus
who don't necessarily present with
symptoms but they're still
spreading the virus and that's what's
happening a lot i guess
because like um i mean it's so
interesting was with the with the whole
thing of like
not being able to recognize that you
have it and
is it is it like in the case of like
sometimes when people have it it's
already kind of late because i we i just
found out today
actually that a really close friend of
ours
he his uncle just passed away from
coronavirus and his wife is a nurse and
she couldn't tell
and so she left home and then she came
back three hours later and he was dead
in the in the house which is kind of
crazy like she's a nurse she's dealing
with the whole clova situation
and she couldn't even see it in him and
now she has to see if she has covey
right you know i and i think it's
right yeah so i think you're right
there's a lot of
of the presentation that's very
similar to like a common cold then
there's people who don't present at all
and then you and then but and then you
have the people who do have the typical
symptoms and it's like really high
temperatures
uh cough everything right and say you
even you're like i think i have
coronavirus by the time you're at that
maximum peak symptomology you've
probably already been shedding it around
you and your
your to your your loved ones um and you
know your family members and your close
contacts
right so it's it's hard because by the
time you realize
i think i may have it then you already
have to start talking to people about
uh i'm you know i may have exposed
you know my wife my kids you know
certain people i guess like
if i were to ask you especially because
like you work in a hospital do you feel
like people
maybe even around you don't really
understand the severity of the virus
actually let me ask you this first what
the [ __ ] is a virus
let's let's go back into the basics
because i feel like we're throwing this
word virus and you know
like bacterial infection around i don't
think a the general public such as
myself
i don't know the difference between a
virus and a bacterial infection and why
a virus is more severe than
you know something like the common cold
like why what
what is what's what's the difference
right
uh so basically if you're looking at a
virus and a bacteria you know they're
both causing
so it's a great question because a lot
of times you're causing
uh probably a similar presentation in a
patient right which is they're
they're sick they you know they might be
sick enough that
they get hospitalized may be sick enough
that they um
can you know stay home a couple days and
get over it um viruses
um and bacteria basically they have very
different um base structural
it's a structural thing so if you if you
look at it you basically look at it
so um with bacteria we've
we've identified um like
different families and kind of like how
bacteria look we like know their
structure we know like what makes up
like certain walls
and gram-negative gram-positive
anaerobic bacteria basically
they're they are um organic things
that we have developed um
antibiotics for yeah
viruses um they're
infectious um agents right
but they're not necessarily something
that
uh that we have
you know it's it's there's a lot of
stuff to get into the weeds but
basically we don't have
uh medication for them be beyond
like uh vaccinations so like and and
basically
our own immunity if someone is already
exposed basically these are infectious
units that cause illness um
after they cause uh illness
people create um essentially you gain
immunity
most people most viruses um
and then that immunity is kind of the
basis of
how we started um coming up with
vaccination like smallpox and all that
stuff basically you see that okay
if i introduce you introduce to you a
inactivated uh form of something like so
influenza or the flu if i like if i
kill this virus like a protein i kill it
um and i give it to you um like some of
its proteins
your body will still look at it and be
like hey this is a foreign
invader in my body um
let's process it break it down and
create antibodies
for it so if we see it again in the
future then
we can respond to it really quickly and
it won't make us sick
so i think when you think so when you
think about when you think about like
viruses and you think about
uh bacteria think about like viruses are
a lot smaller bacteria
bigger bacteria that's like really like
there
we've we've kind of categorized
different families of bacteria
uh we do have there are certain virus
families as well like the coronavirus
like sars mers
uh covet 19 these are all in the same
type of coronavirus family
and it's mostly based on a um like a
protein structure
um and the scary thing about viruses is
that
um they there is basically there's uh
you almost call it like a rearrangement
that they could do sometimes
um remodeling and and and
if they rearrange in a certain way
almost like a transformer then
they can become like our immunity that
we had to it say you already saw the old
version
will not work on the new version it's
just like a new virus to them and they
don't know how to deal with it again
right right so that's that's what they
um a lot of
a lot of what we so um so
sars the uh mers
cover 19 there's a lot of talk about the
theories around
zoonotic viruses so a lot of these
viruses exist in nature already in
animals
like for for example coven 19 people
think
um likely it originated from bats
and the reason we think that is because
there's a lot of
coronaviruses in bats and um
i think after the sars epidemic um
they they sequenced um a
bunch of like some of the viruses and
some of these animals because we were
scared of
you know something jumping from an
animal infecting us
um and then they once they once
this outbreak happened they sequenced
coven 19
and found it to have very high
similarities with one strain of one of
the
viruses so so
you know with these things like a lot of
times you have like a host
animal that has a virus that is only
works in bats
and then um
you know without getting too specific a
lot of times it will
go into another animal which you call
like an intermediate host
so like in the case of mers it was like
camels
right and then um uh and then for this
one it's like uh
for covid it's it's like that funny
animals that ping i think it's like pink
lincoln i i
always forget its name but it's like
that little scary looking the pangolin
pingalan the piglen
so that's the intermediate host where uh
so you had a recombination from when it
was a a bat virus only a recombinant or
a change transformed
went into the inner intermediate host
and then like you have a small change in
the sequence and then it can go into us
and then it just takes off like
gangbusters sorry it's not a super clear
explanation but like it's there's a
there's a there's a lot behind like
bacterial and viral
uh infections yeah but in in general i
guess like just for
for someone like me just bacterial
infections are easier to manage
and viral it's just on a completely
different level
right right so i think for for us
for bacteria um they both these
infections could be very dangerous and
could kill
kill anybody right but um since the
advent of antibiotics
we have um we we have
better techniques for treating bacterial
infections like
we have antivirals like if you think of
hiv those are antivirals
so we had to basically like the human
immunodeficiency
viruses we had to find ways to
try to stop this virus from replicating
within ourselves
um so there are some like antiviral
medications
but you know they tend to be a lot more
expensive a lot more specific
a lot more uh less common than
than say if i hit you with like a
penicillin right
it could get a whole bunch of stuff you
know um
and a whole bunch of uh things that
could make you sick
oh yeah so it's like if you have like a
bacterial infection it's like we'll take
these antibiotics it'll kill
you know whatever that is and there's
just a litany of things that it could
take down versus
a viral medication like the the thing
for the flu this is for the flu
you know exactly it's very it's very
specific exactly so you have to be
um because the virus viruses they're
like their structure
is super unique to that virus
so you have to like that's why
everyone's racing to figure out a
vaccine for the stars because you have
to first
sequence and understand what this virus
looks like
then understand how it spreads then
understand how it replicates in our body
and then in any of those stages
kind of figure out what's a place that
we might be able to interf
intervene and stop this thing from
taking hold
and making you really really sick
because that's also the curious
part too because like if somebody
explains to somebody in in layman's
terms what a
vaccine is right it's like it's a dead
version of the
the virus that's going to affect you and
it gives you your body a chance to
develop antibodies to defend from it
again right
but then i go back and i say well how
come they can't just find that dead
version of throw it in our body real
quick you know
so it's just a lot more complicated
process than that right
right right and you and you think about
it right because you you want
to um there's a lot of there's a lot of
safety and efficacy right because
again this is a very like uh elementary
explanation but
there's a lot of safety and efficacy
that goes into
uh making sure that we're not gonna be
you know the cure isn't worse than the
disease in a sense right
so it's like right i mean i mean like
you want to be able to put something in
someone's body
that um is going to help them get better
but then
also will not make them worse right and
there's so many different you know types
of people on this world as far as
genetics go so we want to make sure that
these things are as safe as possible and
um and then they're tested broadly and
they're effective in any
everybody because say it works in some
people and say it doesn't work in other
people
then you're like why are we going to
mass produce this thing
if it's only going to be effective in a
small percentage of the people or the
populace
so you have to so you have to go through
these um you know
they call them phases right so there's
you know
um fda basically for us in the states
uh phase one two three trials where we
are we're
doing efficacy we're doing safety and
all these different
um stages to make sure that what we're
giving to people
is going to be both effective and safe
safe enough to give to yourself your
parents your kids
um you know there's a standard that we
need
um and but you know that being said
there are um
you know there there are human trials
that people uh
you know when people are very very sick
if there are
um you know experimental things
like trials people could sign up for
those right and i know there are
they're there they have been having some
trials like in washington state when
this first started and other places like
i think
pfizer i think has a you know human
trial of a vaccine going on right now
so certain people will sign up and say
hey you know what i
will be this you know trailblazer and
and take that
and take that risk and those people you
know god bless them they're
they're they are taking on
this unknown this x factor in hopes that
it may help um cure
you know the infection that they have
and then they can recreate it for
everybody else
you know when i was asking you that i
mean i sent you a link the other day and
um
the the person that i'm like like i've
been reading so much random articles
about this stuff and um
you know keith and i talk about here and
there but he sent me a link about those
two
doctors out in bakersfield and they own
like their own
um their own what's the word i'm looking
for urgent care
urgent care they own their own urgent
care whether their own private practice
or whatever
and they had this whole hour-long uh
um not meeting but it was a media thing
right
where journalists came and they were
they're grilling them pretty hard
and they were kind of advocating for
and i don't want to misquote them and
i'm obviously that there's a lot more
specifics if you watch the video but it
got taken down but basically what they
were saying was
um from the stuff that they've seen well
here's here's the first thing they were
talking
one of the one of the journalists asked
him about the the findings of like dr
faushi and all these other people and
their their argument to that was that
dr fashion and them and all these
epidemiologists there there are people
who aren't in the front lines so a lot
of the stuff that they're talking about
is based on information without having
to see actual people
and that what they were saying as
doctors and they're only and they're
only mentioning from
from their urgent care from the numbers
that they've seen
and in comparison to what they've seen
in terms of the mortality rate
and kind of like how it's infecting
people is not that much different from
the flu
and that was their their grounds for
what they're saying just from their
information and the numbers that they've
seen right
from whatever numbers that they've
extrapolated right and so
i guess they were advocating for not a
complete opening up of the country but
for there to be a thought of
okay should we open up to the country
with the numbers that are given every
day because just like you said
these these things that we are so cement
on in terms of facts it's it's
based on the daily it's like this was a
fact today tomorrow another doctor from
another hospital be like well this is
what we saw
okay well these facts are changing right
and i guess like when from what he's
saying from their numbers is that
it's not looking any more different in
terms of death rates
and how it's spreading to be any more
different than the flu
um and so they're saying that there's a
there's a weird balance in this country
where if we do shut down the whole
you know just all these businesses and
how this country is going well we have
to balance
the negative effects that it's also
having on the people besides just how
the
the the disease is affecting or the
virus is affecting us
on just a biological skill right saying
there's like a race there's there's been
a rise in domestic violence and all this
other stuff from
you know shutting down the country and
having people hold up in their house
um and obviously people were really
upset with what they were saying because
there's people who have lost you know
family members for this and we don't
know people who have died i don't know
anybody who's died from the flu
you know but within this within this
last month or two
i already know of people just in arm's
length away from me who have passed away
from covet
right so i guess like from from what
they were saying and
there was a lot of doctors that were you
know going against what they were saying
but in their argument they were saying
that from their friends who also own
you know that their physicians in their
in their state or city or whatever they
also agree with them
so how's how's like covet affecting i
guess like sacramento right because i
don't i don't know how it is in
sacramento
right so um there's a couple things
there um i
you know i think trying to
unpack and and think about um
everyone's day-to-day like struggles
right
i i do i don't want to minimize that
there are a lot of people struggling
with
you know um wanting to make sure they
have
a job and providing food all this stuff
a lot of uncertainty especially when it
comes to mortgages rent
those type of things um
and and other pressures right like
interpersonal
and all those things i do however think
that um we have to be
um very oriented on the number of cases
and the number of new cases specifically
right
so i think like a number of people have
used pretty good analogies with this
i think cuomo did a good job uh new sim
of course here in our state
um you have to
essentially have enough testing in place
that you can take
samples and and and see how many new
cases
of the virus you're getting as you start
to open up right
so i think a lot of the question that
governors are asking themselves
how many cases do we have a day how many
new cases do we have a day
um you know and what
are certain sectors of our society that
we could open up
that would have a low risk
um you know because everything is going
to have a risk
right any interpersonal connection is
going to have a risk of increasing the
number of cases
and the number of of deaths
unfortunately um
until we have a a vaccine or if you know
ho if this thing pitters out at some
point
um but in order for us to open up i
think we have to be
um patient and we have to be aware that
um just because our local cases
may not be at a certain level um does it
um shelter us from staying
at those safe levels right so in
sacramento for example i think we have
um we so we we have we've been at a very
safe number i think last time i checked
it was like maybe
somewhere around 800 900 cases i was
just i was just on second beat this
morning
yeah anyways just in in
in the in the federal or national wide
perspective as far as studies goes it's
been very
mild and i think we've been very
fortunate with some of the early stay at
home
um orders um and you know all the hand
hygiene and all the social distancing
that people did
did a really good job as as a state
right because the projections
initially from our governor's office was
about half the population was going to
be affected
you know and and that didn't happen um
so now i think what where a lot of the
controversy lies
is how do we
open things up in the safest way
possible right
and you're pairing that with a lot of
frustration for a lot of people who
want to get back to their life who have
you know who who feel like they have
been making sacrifices and
at this point they're thinking that you
know it it's worth it to get out there
um but i think it this like everything
that's been done across our
our entire country has saved lives
um in that it you know we haven't had as
many cases
and people dying but then we also in
them in the sense that we don't
overwhelm our hospitals because
you know at my hospital we have a 20 bed
icu
20 beds right oh [ __ ] that is not much
right you know and then between and then
that's our hospital and then there's
the other local hospitals who have you
know some a little bit more some a
little less some
without right and and then so
if you think about it if we start if we
were at
at the stage that new york was and where
you know
or even la where you're having about
like 900
some thousand some cases a day you know
um
and a fraction of those were sick enough
to require a
icu um and if that was happening
on the daily those resources would get
overwhelmed very fast
yeah um so that so so i think you know
we've done it
we've done a good job as a collective
and now i think the uh the frustrating
thing is just kind of is
is trying is trying to find a way
to to ease into things opening up
um and in the hard thing it's you're
asking people to be patient
and i think that there's a lot of people
who are
who are on their last straw yeah yeah
and
and then you're and then you're seeing a
lot of it on social media you're seeing
a lot of it everywhere on the news and
that the protests
but yeah the protesting is so
interesting i mean i'm i'm i'm not one
to talk like first of all
i'm not balling you know what i mean
like this this this whole
government you know intervention of us
like shutting down our businesses and
people also have to understand like i
you know i'm a co-owner of like six food
businesses like especially in the
hospitality business this has definitely
affected me
uh right affected our workers affected
all of our investors everybody who's
been involved in this and it's been kind
of rough right
and i think like i'm trying to wrap my
head around
why actually i can't wrap my head around
it right just because i've seen some
ridiculous videos
and you know i don't want media to go
ahead and warp everything that i'm
thinking about but when i see people
kind of like compare
you know being quarantined for a month
and a half right and
they're comparing it to [ __ ] modern
day slavery they're saying it's modern
day slavery
it's it's the most ridiculous statement
i've ever heard in my life like i i want
to
slap the caucasian somebody get out of
it like
but like i'm gonna slap the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of you right yeah and it's just it's
gotten to that point and this is what
i'm saying it's like you know dave
chappelle said it like people have
[ __ ]
brittle spirits like a month and a half
of staying at home and eating ice cream
and watching tv
has been really rough on you and i'm not
talking about people who had to shut
their business down
i'm not talking about that but there's
people out there who are protesting for
protests because they can't go to the
beach
that that right there is a little odd to
me you know what i mean if you're
protesting because you your livelihood
is at stake right
like you haven't been able to pay your
bills these are the issues that are
arising in your life
i understand like i i i i'm not
i agree i sympathize with you a lot
right because you know we know we we
both grew up really poor and we know how
much it sucks to worry about your
day-to-day bills i know that stress i
know that pressure
but when i see people protesting because
i want to be able to go to the beach
that's when i want to give them the back
hand of god it's like you know what i'm
saying it's like yo
it's been like a month and a half chill
out it's odd for me
it's uh it's definitely one of those
things that i
you know it makes me um have to take a
usa moment
um i you know i do think that um
you know um
like i you know i try to count some of
the positive i think people did a really
good job in the beginning of this
um i also think that you know um
people couldn't you know fear
is a really interesting thing right like
uh
it made people do some really messed up
things like some of the hoarding and
some of the
shopping practices that happened in the
very beginning of this
shelter and place right um there is
there were some very good acts
right that happened same time so um
which restored my faith in some humanity
um
but then i think you know it's been
about what
uh you know you know late early march
since a lot of these things happened
went down yeah um
[Music]
you know i think there's people could
only go so long
and then and if they don't see if it
could be
it's hard because a virus is not
something that you could see
so then when when you look at so when
you look outside
it's the weather's looking good you know
the weather is
nice if you live next to a beach you're
like oh man that looks very inviting
i think unfortunately you don't realize
that things might still be very
precarious until you go out there and
then
um and then unfortunately we start
having numbers start to spike again
so i think that's that's the biggest
concern
is that you know if um and
my theory right you know a lot of these
places are opening up now i think it's
own
i think for california we're probably
you know we're opening up stage
two on on friday um
and then um george is open other states
are opening up
um you know it's gonna happen
right so i think the question is what
happens if these cases start going up
and we start having more
mortality do we shut back down are
people going to be able to
recognize the threat and and i hope that
they will
yeah because it could help i hope it
doesn't go that way though i hope
i hope everything's great i want to be
outside too yeah
i would i would have traveled too i want
to i want to enjoy a beach as well
but you know it's unfortunate times
i i think like i think the thing that
i'm seeing a lot in differences
in in terms of people who live in this
country versus other people right like
like i'm i'm as american as american
[ __ ] kids right
like i was born in korea but i came here
when i was two like if there was a war
between
i don't know like another i'm i'm gonna
be on america's side right that's
i'm i'm an american like this is who i
am and
you know from what i'm seeing and just
to put that out there the reason why i
say that is just sometimes i talk about
like the american spirit like we're
we're so we're so gung-ho about this
country
but you know i think that the foundation
of this country is also that
we don't want to we also want to have
the option to fight tyranny in case our
rights are taken away
and that starts to seep out as like the
root of who we are in this country and
who what it what it is to be an american
and the moment somebody feels like it's
being tampered with people start to get
a little [ __ ] crazy
and when i say it when i talk about
brittle spirit and the reason why i'm
mentioning this is because
i'm comparing it to other my other
friends who live in other countries
right now and i'm asking how it is it's
like oh we're chilling you know
like it's been about it's been about
three months for them and they're like
yeah it's tough you know not being able
to go outside you know the weather's
nice
but like we understand how serious this
is and so we're just going to say it
and you know our government we they have
a belief that the government has their
best interest in hand
right right but then but then again i
also think you know like for example
like a friend of mine in canada says
that there
each person in their household is
getting two thousand dollars a month
until this is over
and you know and our stuff the land of
the free
we're getting that 1200 bump once and
then it's like
yeah good luck good luck you know so you
know i understand both sides but
sometimes it's hard to
it's hard it's going to be hard for
other countries to really empathize with
what we're going on because they have
worse cases and worse scenarios and
they're not sitting there complaining
about you know their situation
so all right it's it's uh it's
definitely um i think it's
it's an interesting time i think it's
definitely revealing a lot of things
about different cultures
and um you know i and even some of the
practices right i think
you know we're we're very um you know
we're we you and i we're both huggers
right we're all
for sure uh i think um we're all very
well aware of some of our um
interpersonal
like habits now oh yeah dude like how
much of an
affectionate hugger i am it's really
there i'm about to hug random strangers
in the supermarket and [ __ ] like
you trying to get some of this i'm
trying to like sell it like it's drugs
and [ __ ] it's like yo you're trying to
get some of this hug real quick like
maybe behind this happen bro let me
let me see what's up you know what i've
realized too that i have to be very very
like mindful and conscious about and a
lot of people have been asking me to
talk about this situation specifically
when it comes to like
you know a lot of hate that you know
asian americans have been getting
and um the reason why i haven't done a
podcast on that yet and
i think i am going to start doing
podcasts about it
and i'm gonna start calling it uh the
the the whole segment which is gonna be
called coughing while asian
and then and the reason why is because
i want to be very careful about how i
what i say and how i feel about things
right because i don't want to come off
as somebody who's just getting caught up
in
whatever the media says and and
sometimes like when i see
the plight of somebody who looks like me
and what they're going through and i
start putting myself in their place i
start getting [ __ ] angry
right and i have to be very careful with
that voice sometimes because i could get
on the other side and just start mowing
people down because
you know just for an example you know
i've been walking around i walk around
in this area called south passage in the
south passes like you went jogging there
it's nice as [ __ ] super diverse
everybody waves and says hi to you
just it's just really dope and but ever
since the copa situation i've had
so far three instances where people
treated me like [ __ ] and that's never
happened before
like and really um i have never
i've never had that [ __ ] happen to me
you know specifically in south pasadena
like for example we were i was
at um la monarca i think i took you
there's that it's the uh
mexican coffee shop right really right
right you know and i told and i might
have told you this but it was it was
that lady who
said you people to me and she was like
this [ __ ] is happening because of you
people now imagine she might have said
like people who are social distancing
but never a good idea to say an attorney
just
psa for everybody listening never a good
phrase
just yeah just don't lead with your
people you know
she's like is that only because of you
people and i heard that [ __ ]
and i was like you know what you might
have met people who aren't social
distancing
however i didn't take it like that you
know
and you know long story short with this
i'm not gonna go i'll tell the whole
story in another podcast but
you know the manager stepped in and she
kind of kicked her out and i had to sit
there and i was like yo i've been living
in this nice like pasadena super diverse
area for the longest [ __ ] time
right right i've been here for about six
[ __ ] years never had a single
instance where somebody said you people
at me or
looked at me like i was an outsider
never ever had that [ __ ] experience
before
yeah and then and this is what we're
talking about when we talk about the
rhetoric
specifically coming from the president
of the united states when he says a
phrase like china
virus right right right um and people
don't understand
how how powerful those words are how it
gives a green light to other people
who've already had
these these bigoted feelings towards a
culture right
and they've never really felt the
strength or the power to say because
it's been in their [ __ ] mind for a
long [ __ ] time
but when the president gives you
strength to say that that's when you
have an instance like me where i've been
in south pasadena for six years one of
the most diverse nicest places i've ever
been
and somebody looks at me at the coffee
shop that i go to on a daily basis
is because of you people and i sat there
and you know at first i kind of laughed
about it which you know as a comic i i
wrote a whole sketch about it but then
afterwards i'm like
hey [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm like yo
[ __ ] you you know and i was like yo i
i'll
[ __ ] slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
right and it kind of opened up this
whole conversation
and especially for a lot of asian
americans for you to really think about
this
and i talk about this too my best friend
he's sitting across from me right now on
this video conference he's
he's an african-american male right i
grew up in a very diverse area
black community asian community right so
you know the the
i call it you know the the black
american pipe is not something that's
foreign to me
right i've seen it with my own eyes like
i've seen disparity i've seen this [ __ ]
my whole life so
when people talk about black american
issues i tend to feel a certain way
about it because i grew up around this
community right like we've
we were around each other my whole life
and so sometimes
i think the one positive thing that came
out from this is that there i know there
are
maybe a handful of asian americans that
see this and they saw when the whole
trayvon martin thing came out right
right and for other people too like in
my asian american community when you saw
this black lives matter movement and i'm
not i'm not saying that a lot of people
that i know
didn't believe in that [ __ ] but there
are a handful of it right but that
moment i heard that you people even
though i understood
what that you people phrase was said
when it was said to another culture like
the black american culture when it was
said to me
i was like it clicked even harder it's
like how [ __ ] dare you
you know like what did i do who what
what did i do
you know and it kind of made me sit
there i was a little frustrated with it
i was like oh
so this is this is what this is what the
black american community is talking
about right now and you never really
know
and then the the a few a few weeks after
that when i was walking this this old
lady
she had a little [ __ ] rake and she
was like i don't see you wearing a mess
make sure that you stay away from me
and i was like hold on a second and so i
was like okay
i wasn't wearing my mask when i was
walking but i was clearly like 12 feet
15 feet away from her
right and i started walking by and i saw
this other white couple going by they
weren't wearing any masks
they were right next to her and she goes
good morning
and i'm like oh okay so this is [ __ ]
interesting
and i wanted to sit there and i'm like
damn this doesn't
and it got to a point where i saw it
repetitively right so there was other
time where this guy was walking a little
too close to me and it was kind of like
being an [ __ ] about it
and i already cursed somebody out i
already cursed that lady out in the in
the in the coffee shop
i already had it and now i start to
realize where sometimes you all you all
you can do is just roll your [ __ ]
eyes
and you get fed up with the [ __ ] it's
like what am i supposed to do now am i
going to suck everybody that comes my
[ __ ] way
you know you get tired get tired of this
[ __ ]
yeah i you know it it's it's hard man i
think um
um it reminds me what is it the martin
luther king quote like injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere yeah right
you know and it's um and you like to
think that
we're in the year 2020 and some of the
you know we're in california it's one of
the very progressive
uh you know blue states um but you know
we're also
a a state that imprisoned a large part
portion of our japanese population you
know after pearl harbor
you know i mean and you like to think
that um
these knee-jerk reactions of uh
stereotyping and
um and and and hate uh won't happen
but no it's they they happen and they've
been happening
here they've been happening globally uh
what is the black people in china too
were like getting like you know turned
away from mcdonald's
i was like i was like that is wild
anyways it's
you know it and it's these things where
um
you like you have to be right like i
don't know like
these things happen but i think it's we
we have to like
join together and stand up for each
other and and make sure that
one you know we all all we all are
dealing
with a very like present threat but it
doesn't mean that
we lose some of that camaraderie between
groups
and and and and and just being an
ally you know if it's not your group if
it's not your person it's being like hey
no that's
that's messed up like yeah and i was and
i have to not get caught up in that [ __ ]
because i also have to mention too on
these walks
there are the you know i could tell like
some of these white people they're like
super sensitive to the situation
they looked me in the eye and they're
like good morning they want to make sure
like hey you're safe with us
and i gotta say that even though i'm
talking about three situations where
that negative thing happened
there were still about 90 or 100 more
situations
where there was a white person that came
up and they said good morning to me they
said hello they smiled at me so
i got to make sure and i want and the
reason why i'm bringing back this whole
thing of being careful about what i talk
about when it comes to these situations
i can't let three [ __ ] [ __ ]
represent
the other 99 of the people that i met
that day right and that's the hard part
right
i think that's a hard part for a lot of
people you see stuff in media you you
have these bad instances with a specific
culture
but you have to look at the i look at
the numbers it's like listen if that's
three people out of like
whatever 100 or 200 people that i saw in
the last week then
who am i to go here and judge this whole
group of people from these one from
these few
individuals who made that mistake right
but it doesn't make me want to sock them
in the [ __ ] face my god i just wanted
to just
oh i could just strangle you [ __ ] oh my
god
yeah no i've had some positive
experiences with people
so i think i i think even though like
you what you say is true and there are
people who are being
horrible to each other and people who
are hoarding toilet paper
for no good reason i don't know why
there there have been a lot more i know
there's a lot more kindness i think in
the streets and i think that
sometimes when something like this
happens you do have
uh people like you know it's almost like
they don't sweat the small stuff anymore
so it's so it's like hey you know
like this like familial beef that i had
with you
over whatever like no we're just we're
just worried about everybody being safe
we just want you know mom and dad to be
safe we want our kids to be safe
make sure we got enough food like i'm
not even beefing about that twenty
dollars you owe me
i mean let me catch you in august
yo when this panda has been sober it's
gonna be back but for now just be safe
but
you gave me that 20 spot yeah like
you're gonna rub me that 20. you know i
mean
i think it's like it's it's like yeah
it's cute right now but i don't need
that 20
because that's when the stimulus check
runs out
yo a lot of people are you know because
i guess like it's just the stimulus
checking and on top of that
there's the government assistance with
the uh the corona
yeah with the unemployment together and
it's a it's a good amount of money for a
lot of people
like i know a couple of my friends
who've it's like an extra 600 bucks a
week
that's cool yeah it's 600 bucks a week
not including your unemployment
so it's that compounded with that that's
good i
i hope that you know um
[Music]
you know my concern is too like when we
come out of this
um it will be a very
big rebuild economically for everybody
so i hope there's still jobs
yeah people have employment because you
know i think there's gonna be a point
when
we're like all right people gotta get
back to work and i hope there's still
jobs and people
are able to you know carry on with their
lives and we don't have a lot of the
you know there's a lot of remember back
when the 2008 a lot of the mortgages and
people getting yeah yeah
homes and all that stuff and i that's
that's my concern too
man i've been i've been you know because
i go through instagram i've been
spending so much more time on my phone
it's disgusting
but like i get seeing all these
instagram stories people like putting up
these posts of like
listen if you don't gain a new skill
during this quarantine
it means that it's not the fact that you
didn't have
the the the the opportunity is because
you didn't have
the [ __ ] the mind state for it i'm
like you shut the [ __ ] up
all right i'm gonna eat ice cream i'm
gonna eat some ice cream
and i'm gonna wallow for a little bit
you don't tell me [ __ ]
people trying to be motivational
speakers now i've seen a lot of people
from sacramento too they over here just
showing their new talents
on their bucket list [ __ ] clown all
these [ __ ]
what kind of what kind of talents do
they have well i'm talking about these
doing instagram lives and [ __ ] now
they're like yo
i'm doing this hey guys what's up i'm
doing an instagram like guys
it's like three people in this room
[ __ ] turn that [ __ ] off
what are you talking about talking about
guys
guys man it's me and 30 other people
that are your friends turn that [ __ ] off
[ __ ] ridiculous david are you gonna
start at only fans
oh i already did instagram
instagram be silent and me trying to
sign this me son
yeah yeah yeah you gonna be out there
showing all
all your risque pictures damn straight i
will dude
i mean for you i mean just to kind of
wrap this up i guess like if you were to
give some people on how to deal with the
whole corona thing and this is just
somebody who's a yummy
you're you're a general physician i'm a
family doctor right family medicine yeah
yeah family medicine to stuff i mean
i i guess like if you could tell people
from your experience
like what would be the safe safe thing
to do
as of right now and how they should like
practice like social distancing like
what could you tell people
right i mean i think most people like
you know i want to give you the benefit
of the doubt most people are
are pretty smart i think it's um
you know it's it's being very uh
particular about
um when you go out um
in what kind of groups you're gathering
and what you're doing right so i think
there's essential things like you have
to get your groceries
yeah yeah you know um if you're still
working
right you're a central worker you have
to go to work um
you know it's it's making sure that you
have your face mask
you're washing your hands you're
you're trying to avoid um
like you know i know it's summer time
right but like birthdays
um uh parties uh
little things that i i know are going to
start happening again
you know i think you want to be cautious
about doing that
and one of the most powerful things that
i heard
is is you know if yeah you might be
young
like you specifically watching this
you're probably a young
healthy person who doesn't have a lot of
comorbidities
but you know your parents may not be and
your uncles or aunts or grandparents may
not be
or you may have you know a relative or a
friend who's
has a condition that you may not be all
the way aware of
and what if you're one of those people
who doesn't have symptoms and you spread
something to them
that's that's a a huge trauma
and and thing that could happen to
somebody else and then they'll be on you
yeah um so i think it's it's you know
and i want to be over here just
scare tackling everybody but it's just
but it's it but it's just it's just be
cautious
be careful you know and let's just like
watch florida and georgia
let's watch them first people let's see
what happens to those [ __ ]
atl popping flow rider flow rider
let me hold on let me let me try it let
me try a little bit better to give you a
better let me uh i was thinking about
the bacteria
first back the audio audio kind of
backed out what happened can you hear me
yeah then it goes yeah okay uh let me
try better like
let's see if we could use this as a
bacteria uh virus definitions you could
splice this um bacteria
a little bit bigger right viruses are a
lot smaller
bacteria are living organisms viruses
tend to be small
non-living parasite things um
that height that can't replicate by
themselves
and they need to hijack your own
biological
machinery to replicate
so uh bacterial they are growing
and they are you know dividing and
breeding
you know and you could have a huge
bacterial infection
but they don't need to hijack your cells
in order to
multiply like a virus so like hiv
corona virus all these viruses need to
get inside you
get inside your cells take over your
hijack your machinery like think of a
bit like those
like those uh bots and the matrix like
they're flying around
they implant in your in your stuff
they're crawling around to get inside
your machinery to take over your whole
system
yeah so that's how i like to think about
and
and we have antibiotics and we can stop
bacteria because they are organic
materials yeah organic things
biological things so we could stop them
viruses
we have to specifically find
um catered um like like just
like think of it like as a scalpel we
have to be very precise
how we react to those things unless
um yeah we have to be very sp uh precise
so
that's that's the big thing with viruses
and um
and bacteria they both exist in a huge
amount in nature they're naturally
occurring things
viruses exist in all different species
from you know in the case of coronavirus
and bats
um and and you know all over things and
then and
and then bacteria are all over the place
too in the soil
we have them in our bodies there's good
bacteria there's bad bacteria all that
stuff it's everywhere
yeah so so that's kind of um when people
think about bacterial infections viral
infections those are the big things
they tend to happen um
around the same time of year um
and it's very hard to tell the
difference between the two um
if you are um you know the time if you
don't get really really really sick if
you get really really sick and you go to
the hospital
there's tests that we could do to to to
differentiate between the two
but at home oftentimes it's hard for you
to tell the difference
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
um this is gabito if he happens to be
your family physician just to let you
know you are in the worst hands
if if someone comes in and they tell me
like oh i saw you on geniusbeat i'm like
all right we'll be switching you to a
different provider
right now that's it for entertainment
baby i was like listen i'm still not
getting checks from that show
so you be gone people
uh hopefully hopefully this worked like
i know the audio was going in and out a
bit
um you recorded something on your end i
recorded something in my mind yeah you
got yours on your i mean either way i
i think we uh we got most of it but uh
yeah people wanted to
i wanted people to talk to somebody who
knows what the [ __ ] they're talking
about like i'm
i really ask questions like on some of
the basic level stuff because i know for
a fact if i don't know you [ __ ]
don't know either
right like especially when it comes to
the difference between a bacterial
infection
a viral you know viruses and [ __ ] like
that this is like basic information that
a lot of people just glaze over and i'm
guilty as well
like before i go ahead and talk about
this i'm like this virus is an issue and
then somebody goes what's a virus i'm
like listen man
get out of my house like that's all i
got i'm like oh [ __ ] i actually don't
know what a virus is i don't know
how this spreads i don't know how it
affects my body all i know is that it's
bad you know you know um
it's it's there's a couple pieces of
popular media that i think did a really
good job
um so i was telling you about it on our
phone call earlier
but the the netflix like limited series
on the coronavirus
um pandemic yeah
it did a really good job with some of
the background history
right i think the ted talk that bill
gates has
when he talks about preparing for or
i saw that you mentioned that and bill
gates was warning people like this the
next biggest issue is going to be
something like covid and he was talking
about it and then boom he goes we are
not prepared for this our hospitals
aren't prepared
and this [ __ ] was right right
and
you know and the best thing about bill
bill gates he's not out here
saying i told you so he's just like yeah
well we'll we're still
in this fight um he's in the he's in
he's in that documentary on netflix i'm
sure some of your
your followers have watched it yeah
contagion
the movie um i think matt damon's in
there
yeah yeah it they actually i think they
did it
soon after the sars pandemic so a lot of
like the concepts they talked about as
far as the
you know you have to take you know you
know take with a grain of salt it's
it's fiction but you know with some of
the spread the droplet spread and the
fomites and then they even talked about
social distancing
um they and of course they had to drama
uh you know the
the riots that they showed were a little
bit more extreme it makes for better
entertainment value but a lot of that
stuff like it's similar right so it's
very parallel dude i was like oh [ __ ]
right like i was watching it and then i
was like this is pretty uncanny
um so i think there's there's things out
there that you know represent
like pretty good source of information
but again at the end of the day i would
say listen to your um
local public health um i think in
california
governor newsom is operating um
under the direction of his public public
health officials and
um and i think they're doing a great job
governor cuomo is doing a great job dr
faushi is a superstar
so um i dr burke's i think there's a lot
of people who have putting out some good
information
and just be a little skeptical if people
start
bringing up the 5g towers to zone oh
yeah shout out to trump for uh
suggesting that we just
blast ourselves with uv rays and inject
ourselves
with bleach
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] gold dude don't do
that
don't do that that [ __ ] when he said
that and he looked
over and it was his uh it was his uh
what what did she do she's the uh the
[ __ ]
she deals with kelly yeah burke's berks
terry and she was like what the [ __ ] she
had that look of like what the [ __ ] is
this fool saying it's like
uh yeah i think we looked into uh
blasting our skins with uv rays you mean
the [ __ ] that causes skin cancer
great let's do that please please let's
do that you jackass i was like oh my god
this is we live in a parallel universe
this is so
when he said that [ __ ] i was like is
this a joke is he for real
yeah it's uh you know i can't defend
also i've been touching my face a lot
but i've been i sanitized and nobody
touched myself
just i don't i don't want to be over
here people hit not like getting on me
like they get off ouchy
but um but yeah no i think that's that's
that's it wash your hands often
social distance look it's it's right now
as we film this
it's you know the beginning of may um i
think
things are gonna start opening up uh by
june
and i just say like yeah take take take
it slow
take it slow don't like dive right in
don't go book wild you know give it a
little time
and then um and then just kind of uh pay
attention to the news and kind of see
uh what updates people are putting out
you know about safe practices but i
think you know
overall i want to say good job to
everybody because you have been at home
for the most part and you've been
fighting with your partner i don't know
what's up with that
and you've been doing all you know
you've been doing all those sacrifices
and um we in the healthcare community we
really appreciate you just because
it's been keeping our hospital numbers
very manageable
um so we're not overwhelmed so i think
for us we want to say thank you
everyone's been saying thank you to
us thank you to you and of course all
our all the people in our hospital that
you guys don't always see that keep it
running
um everybody's been you know has stepped
up
well that's got beethoven
uh we will see you guys next time
remember genius brain uploads every
thursdays and sundays and
uh yeah other stuff than that uh i'm
here to keep you guys company on your
commute i know this podcast was a little
different but
i wanted to uh address this because
people have been asking so
uh peace out [ __ ] love you